wired to a homes electrical system a
standby generator automatically powers
up in the event of an outage production
starts with the stator it's the
stationary core of the alternator the
part that converts energy from the motor
to electricity a press compacts a
hundred or more laminated steel discs to
create the stator core machinery lifts
the stator core out of the assembly
device and transfers it to the next
station here an automated system
insulates the numerous slots in the core
meanwhile at another station an
automated system whines copper wire onto
a mandrel this configures the copper
windings to fit the core slots
once all the windings have been
correctly arranged on the threading tool
the technician is ready to transfer them
to the stator core he places the stator
on top of the threading tole and
activates a hydraulic device that pushes
the wires up through the tool and into
the slots of the stator core then it's
into the lacing machine
this machine crochets a string wrap
around the bundles to hold the wires
together with the wiring precisely wound
and wrapped this important generator
component is ready for the finishing
touch
a clear varnish to produce the
alternator's rotating part the rotor the
technician stacks laminated steel discs
to the same height as the stator core he
lubricates the opening in the center of
the disks he inserts a shaft and a press
pushes it into the stack to complete the
installation then it's over to an
automated welder the machine grips the
rotor at both ends and slowly turns it
as a robot welds both caps to the rotor
body the technician unclamped the rotor
from the welding machine and then tucks
insulation into slots on the sides the
rotor then goes for a spin in a machine
that winds bands of copper wire around
the insulated sections these wires will
act as electromagnets and help her to
this electrical current they're now
ready to assemble the standby generator
using a lift the technician lowers the
engine into position he joins the rotor
shaft to the engine crankshaft next up
is the stator
the technician slides the stator onto
the rotor he anchors the stator and
rotor to the generator base he attaches
a motorized carbon brush two copper
rings on the rotor shaft the brush will
collect electricity from the shaft and
transfer to the generator controller he
secures it to the end bracket with
screws he connects the wiring harness
that moves electricity from the brush to
the controller he links the other end of
the harness to the engine he plugs in a
sensor to monitor oil pressure and makes
all the other electrical connections the
assembly of this standby generator is
complete